so I've been getting a lot of email
lately from people saying David you know
I'm seeing what appear to be a bunch of
ads on your videos is the YouTube ad
boycott solved to the extent that it
could be solved and sadly the answer is
no so to explain what's going on we I'll
put up our revenue chart for you we were
having a grand old 2017 and as you can
see at the beginning of the year we had
some great YouTube revenue going we were
in an expansion phase we had all sorts
of great stuff planned for you and then
at the end of March beginning of April
at the number two on this graph the
revenue just fell off a cliff we lost 99
percent of our YouTube revenue and what
happened was no individual did anything
evil except for maybe one guy at the
Wall Street Journal who wrote a horribly
dishonest article but that being that
bad aside YouTube panicked because a
bunch of advertisers threatened to
boycott YouTube because some ads showed
up next to offensive and racist content
and in an attempt to not lose the
YouTube revenue from these advertisers
YouTube put in an overly aggressive ad
algorithm which basically eliminated ads
from our channel and that lasted about a
month and a half
eventually at point three on this graph
we started to see some recovery in our
ad revenue and I was sort of hopeful
that this meant we were on the mend and
everything was on the up-and-up and
sadly at the beginning of July revenue
fell off a cliff down 85 percent and
that's really where we are now so to
answer your question no the revenue
problem hasn't been solved the New York
Times has taken an interest in what's
going on with the David Pakman show
YouTube channel Amanda Hess wrote a
great article called how YouTube's
shifting algorithms hurtle independent
media Wired magazine is taking an
interest davey alba from Wired wrote
another article about us called want a
better web here's an idea
pay for it and really you know the
there's an upside and there's a downside
here maybe we would call it a silver
lining we have been making it very clear
for a long time that the most valuable
way that we are funded is directly by
viewers of the show
and listeners to the show the podcast
the radio show YouTube etc and so we've
had the membership program for several
years so that allowed us to weather the
storm of the YouTube ad boycott in a way
that not all other youtubers were able
to do and we are continuing to try to
build our membership support so what I
want to offer to you and say if you like
the job that we're doing if you like the
content we put out if you're interested
in all of these great long-form videos
and deep dives that we're doing and the
critical thinking mini series that's
planned and so many other great things
consider getting a membership and it's
not a lot of money if you go to david
pakman.com slash membership you'll be
presented with the main membership page
you can choose a monthly or yearly plan
they start at $6 a month or $60 for the
year and if even those prices are too
high and I'm sensitive to that for a lot
of people that is a lot of money after
you click on the red signup button
you'll be taken to page two of the
membership sign-up process and you'll
see a field that says coupon code if you
want a 40% discount and this is it's up
to you right if you want the discount by
all means take it you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 now it's really important as
you see the code there it's all
lowercase and there are no spaces it's
one word I voted 17 that will give you a
40% discount and you know as I said
before we estimate only about one
percent of our audience is financially
supporting the show and that's okay
that's okay because I want the program
to be a bit available for free to
everybody even if you're signing up at a
discount it still makes a real
difference for us because if enough
people do that and we can go from one
percent of our audience supporting the
show financially to two percent of the
audience supporting the show financially
that's a big coup that's a big
accomplishment for us now if you want
the show to disappear don't do anything
and there's a lot of you haters out
there and I'm not even talking to you I
am talking though to the people that
understand that diversity of voices and
media are currently under attack we've
got a president talking about libel
lawsuits and trying to roll back net
neutrality and we've got the YouTube ad
boycott it's a tough world out there
right now for shows like ours if you are
sensitive to that and
want to maintain diversity of voices
consider signing up for a membership and
you can read about all the great member
benefits two of my favorite benefits are
the bonus show there's an extra show we
do every single day just for our members
and the commercial free audio and video
streams that are out there just for our
paid subscribers